okay so I spoke earlier this week on the
Joe Rogan program for close to an hour
about the drama with YouTube and
right-wingers steven crowder who I
learned on the Rogen program is
apparently a comedian I didn't know that
because I hadn't ever seen him do
anything funny but I guess some of the
stuff is supposed to be funny so I don't
want to redo that entire story because
it seems that every six hours it's
changing in some way but the short
version of it just to kind of set the
stage for this conversation is that
steven crowder set a whole bunch of
homophobic stuff about a vox journalist
named Carlos Mazda who's openly gay
including that Mazda is a lispy Mexican
queer Crowder did it while wearing a
shirt that says socialism is for figs
figs right so I mean what's wrong with
socialism is for a type of sweet fruit
nothing could possibly be wrong with
that now initially YouTube said no
problem what Crowder did does not
violate our Terms and Conditions
then there was blowback and YouTube said
actually it does violate our Terms and
Conditions we're going to demonetised
Steven Crowder's entire account then
they said well even though that's what
we're doing he can get the monetization
back and I'm going from memory here if
he removes a link to the socialism is
for FIGS t-shirt and makes a couple of
other relatively modest changes so
here's how the debate sort of topics
have broken down about this roughly 45%
of the debate is did steven crowder
violate YouTube's Terms & Conditions or
not looking at the terms and conditions
that prohibit targeting and harassment
of individuals particularly on the basis
of membership in groups like LGBT or
whatever else that that's been like
forty five percent of the debate another
forty five percent of the debate has
been should YouTube Terms and Conditions
even be allowed to limit what is
monetizable or what is allowed right so
this is a broader free speech question
and a question about regulation should
should these platforms be forced to be
considered should the lobby change so
that they are considered public
accommodations and thus aren't allowed
to limit speech beyond what is illegal
in any way nine percent roughly I mean
you know I think we understand these are
not exact numbers nine percent of the
conversation has been does being a
comedian excuse you from
having to follow those terms and
conditions or does it differently does
it allow us to differently interpret how
your content should be evaluated and I
have argued for a while and this sort of
came up on the Joe Rogan program a
little bit that you can't you know in
the same way that the right says the
left can't use identity politics as a
cudgel to suppress discussion the right
should not be allowed to use this is a
comedian to excuse or to get out from
under just normal criticisms of whether
what someone is doing is accurate or not
whether it is discriminatory or not
whether it is harassment or bullying or
not that's been like 9% of the
conversation almost completely missing
from this conversation I brought it up
on Rogan is that this is all about money
and that this YouTube situation is very
likely to trigger the next ad pocalypse
did steven crowder actually violate
YouTube's Terms and Conditions with
targeted homophobic harassment of Carlos
masa the answer to me is obviously yes
but I don't actually believe it's the
most important topic here since any
platforms terms and conditions are going
to be subjective to a degree and open to
interpretation so it's not going to
resolve any principle of how content
should be regulated and monetized to
focus too much on Crowder's obvious
violation of the terms and conditions
should YouTube be allowed to limit what
is monetizable via terms and conditions
that are stricter than anything that's
not illegal is monetizable this is all
so simple right now legally YouTube is a
hundred and ten percent absolutely
allowed to monetize or not monetize
whatever they want there are 110 percent
allowed to prohibit content from their
platform as they wish as long as it
doesn't violate non-discrimination along
protected classes YouTube would not be
allowed to say we don't allow Muslim
people to publish videos to YouTube they
would not be allowed to say white men
are not allowed to publish videos to
YouTube but right now they can obviously
say homophobic content is not allowed or
it's not monetizable or whatever now
some people want that changed and that's
okay the law needs
to change to regulate platforms like
YouTube as public accommodations if
that's what you want it's a reasonable
debate should it be changed we can
discuss it but that's not the way the
law is right now is being a comedian and
excuse as far as the YouTube policies
it's not an excuse
the really important thing that is not
being discussed
Kyle kolinsky talked about it I talked
about it privately with some other hosts
but it is barely being discussed is that
this entire thing is likely to trigger
the next ad pocalypse ad pocalypse 1.0
was April of 2017 we lost for a period
of like three weeks ninety nine point
eight percent of our YouTube revenue the
channel was some days making under a
dollar because brands pulled out of
YouTube or threatened to pull out of
YouTube because racist videos had ads
appear in front of them that was at
pocalypse 1.0 ad pocalypse 2.0 was less
acute it was less sort of well defined
it was another period of time with a
very high level of what I call softie
monetization where lots of individual
videos are put in a limited monetization
state the videos are allowed they just
barely run any ads and they don't make
any money I said on the Joe Rogan
program that this is fundamentally about
money this entire Crowder thing in terms
of how YouTube is handling it is about
money and it's about how will YouTube's
advertisers react to what is going on
this carlos mazda steven crowder
situation however is it's resolved on
the individual case level is going to
make some advertisers panic ads for Coke
appearing on racist videos made
advertisers panic this much attention
including articles in the verge and
RealClearPolitics and everywhere about
brand safety and homophobic content on
YouTube this can only have one effect on
YouTube advertisers and it's to get them
to say this is too hot for us let's move
our ad dollars elsewhere this is not
going to attract advertisers to YouTube
YouTube going back and forth about
whether homophobic targeting is or isn't
monetizable is going to freak
advertisers out and who's going to
suffer the most from this it's going to
be independent
like ours it's going to be shows like
ours that are big enough that we do rely
on YouTube revenue but not so big that
we can just flip a switch and get that
revenue elsewhere when it disappears
this is why as I said earlier in the
discussion about the ad boycott that has
successfully led to Bayer bailing on the
Laura Ingraham show on fox news and
tucker carlson on fox news no matter
what side of the political spectrum
you're on this is a nonpartisan analysis
beyond the fact that there's a lot of
right-wingers defending the homophobic
content of steven crowder but putting
that aside my argument is let's
disconnect funding from an algorithm
controlled by a huge corporation subject
to the mood of advertisers who advertise
on the platform or threatens to stop
advertising or actually stop advertising
on the platform let's sever that
financial relationship by directly
funding the programs that you like and
that you want to see have full freedom
to cover whatever they want and not to
have to even think about decisions
related to is this video going to be
demonetised is my entire channel going
to be d monetized because of some coke
ad appearing on a racist video or
because steven crowder
is wearing a socialism for Figgs shirt
while saying that carlos masa is a lispy
gay queer or let's be clear Mexican or
whatever he said let's disconnect it the
solution is simple let's fund the
programs directly this is why I've been
talking about it's not just for fun that
I talk about membership it actually can
make us immune from these ad pocalypse
ease one of which seems to be building
right now